hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lam waifu and i am
incredibly surprised that this has never
happened before but guess
what i managed to skip an episode which
means some of what i'm about to say
later will make no sense at all because
what i'm going to say at the beginning
also i can't go back in time and unsee
what i'm going to see but a lot of what
i say later is still relevant to my
experience so we'll see how much things
stop making sense
anyway so jing has a thing he's hunting
jing's thing
he's a hunter on a hunt and i suddenly
get the feeling that if natero had
chosen who he wanted to be his vice
president he'd have chosen jing right
that's kind of the impression i'm
getting
where jing is disappearing to at any
given time no one knows and i can only
assume it's to hop on his flying dragon
on a flying dragon saw cause if i'm
honest
if i had a flying dragon saw i would
absolutely be on that instead of here
watching people vote because i still
even though i have seen future episodes
and the one that is next in the chain
i still do not understand what is
happening here the rat is being all
cryptic cody and that's great and all
but i don't really want cryptic and i
don't want to see a smug smiling sparkle
face anymore
we got that with puff and this guy just
isn't as good he's disappearing hunters
but i don't know why they're not even
dead just gone and he keeps saying
oh not gone uh god they they have
vanished and he just keeps saying things
that seem reasonable
so all i have to go on of his
deceitfulness is the green-haired animal
lady oh and the fact that he questioned
whether coercion was a bad thing that's
not
great i guess so i get that he's not
good that's a good indicator but i've
seen enough of this show to know that no
one in it is really good
everyone is of questionable morality we
just spent an entire arc questioning
humanity
this is known and clear humans are awful
in this world so why would jing be any
different
i suppose animals like hunters but what
happens when the hunters are animals
what happens when the animals are
hunters and where did this panda come
from
all i'm getting from the voting system
at this point in episode 138 is a whole
lot of political maneuvering that seems
to be based on the idea that jing is the
only one who can save natera's wishes by
hunting down whatever or whoever he's
hunting
and while i'm probably supposed to think
that's the rat i don't think it is
i just don't know what it's supposed to
be if there's a bigger game at play
here because of the behaviors involved
and the amount of rules involved
i'm struggling to get it my brain
doesn't want it
on the other hand we have killer at this
i must say yes there's a whole lot of
new and understood including the
flashback pain
sort of new storytelling mode that and
i'm not sure what to
make of it nor what i make of it
artistically it's interesting and
different and it's helpful for me to
know when we're in the past and when
we're in the past year past
honestly i much prefer this method of
exposition if we're going to get it show
me how creepy this kid is
it's actually pretty wonderful how
horrifying very simple concepts can be
all the kid is asking for is very simple
things and the idea of using the next
set of requests to help
pay for the previous wish is a
fascinating one because it's also
consistent with a child's behavior
ask too much of a kid and yes they're
going to ask a lot of the next people
they meet because they expect to need to
it's a great lesson in expectations
passing the buck and realistic requests
alaka's just a little kid he she they
are just a little kid regardless of
where they came from
and that adorable little kid simply
empties when it's wish time
that alica's parents didn't know about
her abilities is very interesting
that they didn't question his appearance
in their household or question
why them is even more interesting and
that keel wise the only one who has
thought to use the wish to ask what the
deal is with the kids says a whole lot
about why they're afraid of them
while kilwa is not kiwa being a
protective brother really does
spawn from his disbelief that his
parents are afraid of his siblings
abilities
i mean yes they have good reason to
don't get me wrong this kid could end
the world but you'd think that maybe
they would try to solve the situation a
different way like it's just an easy way
just ask the kid
what what's going on though what exactly
you know could they have done beyond
following the rules set out by kiwa or
just do exactly what i said like just
just just ask again like what's wrong
with that that's a wish go for it
speaking of parents i know for a fact
that at points i've said kilowatt's dad
is annoying i still believe
this but he's letting his son try to
rescue gon because he cares about his
son and is trying to teach him good
morals
that or the blood bond thing is a nan
ability and kilwa's returning to the
fold of a family one
alaka driven step at a time i could well
imagine his dad has used alika's ability
to make sure killa comes home or some
such or that the nan ability does that
but
i'm i'm not sure one thing is sure and
clear
and fair and all of those things i'm
intrigued by how
kilwa plans to help gone given we know
how much danger he's putting people in
and the fact that gone could die as a
result of the wish being cast
anyway which means coming back to life
then going away from life
and maybe maybe coming back again i
don't know not only that but the whole
amine subuni thing leads me to believe
that they're traveling together because
if something happens to alaka
it's going to have been tsubune losing
the closest person to her
which is amane right so maybe they're
just there to
make the wishing easy and die that's
cold
that's really really cold let's move on
to the next episodes
kilwa is on his way to seek out his
brother alaka
i do wonder how we were supposed to know
that's what he was doing like it just
there's such a big jumping content that
i was floundering for the first few
minutes pausing to go back and see if
i'd missed something in the previous
episode
up top we're told who alaka is and
that's nice because we're also then told
that there's a reason this child is
locked away
in a room that's really pretty but
creepily
secure and hisoka is suddenly implicated
you know we got his key back you know
what that's a great moment actually when
after all of it hisoka does try to imply
the obvious that kiwa loves gone and
that's the most entertaining moment of
this episode i think because finally
someone else
other than me acknowledges the
relationship between kilauea and gone
and of course it's the man
with the most romantic reading of the
whole series
the major issue i'm encountering here is
that when we consider the overall story
of hunter hunter the person who's front
and center on all the merch is
unconscious
and a magical wish is going to bring him
back from the brink of death in what is
visibly the last and possibly shortest
arc of the series
and while i'm trying hard to maintain my
watch each episode and continue
thinking and while i'm trying hard to
maintain my watch each episode and
consider it as part of the overall as we
go stance on things
i'm really struggling to ignore the fact
that i'm seeing the end of the series
and feel like the arc is going to be
over before it began thanks to being
spoiled by the chimera ant arc you were
all so desperate for me to consume
because having finished that arc why am
i still watching
because you know besides my casual
slamming of the series it doesn't look
like a bad storyline i just think it
probably should have come before the
antarctic despite the fact that it's
purely there
to be a denouement for it and maybe
that's how i'll look at it this is the
tying up of loose ends the circle of
life
the cleaner i do actually love the way
the world is structured and i like the
ways in which it deviates from our own
which isn't something i could have
realized until now having been through
so much
meanwhile we have milky boy moo cow man
is back in the picture and you know what
after all this time we still don't know
where he went or what he was doing
i'm still angry i'm angry about that
like i'm actually genuinely upset about
that that's annoying but he's back
presumably with his falcon
being the stranger danger he was always
supposed to be the qr did what his
parents didn't expect was great i guess
but not
unexpected for us i also didn't quite
understand what he was supposed to do
versus what he did do
so maybe i'm missing something there
either way kilwa now has a cute kid
that's not necessarily human but is his
brother so let's get into the next
episode and see what he does with the
kid as he tries to rescue gon
alaka and something else oh and in case
you're wondering what i thought of the
voting part of the episode
i didn't my brain entirely blanked it
out let's move on to 140. episode 140
you don't realize how much you miss
leorio's earnest angry goodness until
he's back
earnest and angry you know leorio is one
of the few characters in the series i
think who can pull off comedic drama and
it's a very specific trait i think
taking on a dramedy sort of flavor and
it's such a clear and distinct
experience that i'm glad he came and
made the hunter vote worth watching
leorio has always had very specific and
unmalleable values
so having him turn up with a specific
desire of looking after his friends and
now with the upgraded ability to punch
through the floor into someone's face
looking like a certain guy with a gum
gum fruit more to the point i think
there's a world in which he's the
protagonist of the show
i mean he's sort of narratively cast as
one of the protags but i but because he
hasn't been present for much of the show
we don't really know you know the
important thing at this point is that
he's the only one willing to call jing
on his awful parenting
and if we think back to when i was
talking about how monsters are born i
said that it was part culture now if we
take a look-see at what's going on here
we have a kid who left the safety of his
home to follow his dad's dream because
he needed to know why he was abandoned
as a child and this is where he's ended
up because that same father strung him
along
i'm not saying gone being a gaseous nen
form is all his dad's fault but i'm not
not saying that you know you know
the fact that gone is a strange burning
husk and there is no exorcist strong
enough to fix him is quite interesting
he gave himself a restriction and a
covenant and while i don't know what
that means in
story terms i know what a restriction is
and i kind of know what a covenant is
and i recall he said he didn't care and
decided to just throw all of him into
doing a thing
burning out like the sun is a very
impulsive thing to do but i mean
you know be careful and the fear on that
woman's face says everything about the
cost of the wish that's going to be
needed to deal with that so he's just
making kilwa
pay more again and of course he's going
to pay for that
with alaka and miss trunchbull i love
that kilo is one of the strongest danger
kids in all of dangerdome and yet miss
trunchbull i mean tzubone
can freak him out to the extent that he
didn't realize she would do something to
ensure no one else could get hurt on the
way
and of course i love the idea that
there's a subani hiding behind every
tree until the end of the arc and we
just never see her again until we see
like she's being a yoga tree like hmm
i am zen with one less fingernail
looking at the butlers for a second i'm
glad we're seeing canary back because
she's
a badass cool looking character but just
quietly the whole black sacrifice trope
is tired
so i'll leave it at that but i'm not
looking forward to the idea of her dying
some horrible heroic death for someone
who doesn't value her the way she should
be
it doesn't help that the canary in the
coal mine is always the first to die
you know that being the harbingers of
death and all i just don't want that
with all the potential for destruction
over everything else i'm tentatively
interested in this side of things while
not at all interested in who becomes the
leader of the hunters association
so i still have nothing at all to say
about that beyond kaboom
and with that kaboom of a knockout
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this disapproving look at
replacing netero click here here
and here do the fun things make sure you
have
a lollipop and i'll see you next time